allora fermi fermi fermi 190esimo
episodio allora siamo arrivati a un
punto in cui tutti i livelli che vedete
nella schermata quella dei livelli più
belli di tutto happy with siamo ragazzi
appunti quello che cercate una marea e
quindi devo fare slalom tra quelli che
nuovo che ho fatto e quelli che non ho
fatto perché ovviamente non sono andato
in ordini di eugenio spero di non
peccare nulla che io abbia già fatto
ovviamente ce ne sono tanti non ancora
fatto però ormai siamo arrivati in quel
momento in cui non so quali non ho fatto
devo andare ragazzi sui titoli che mi
attirano di meno perché quelli che mi
attirano di meno sono quelli che magari
non ho fatto proprio che mi ha attirato
di meno il titolo quindi vediamo se
riesco a non fare livelli già fatti ko
mi piacciono i treni ecco questo ad
esempio l'ho già fatto no non è vero
l'ho fatto no mi ricordavo che mi piace
l'inter però magari mi sto sbagliando
frames mi sa che ho già fatte avevo
chiesto che il tenero quindi aiuto
abbandonato non avrei mai fatto livello
chiamato abbandonato in direzione porca
vacca salve oddio sta vagando porca
vacca laga un di valori e per che cos'è
world on the rock dvd e su c'è chi è
quel tg e del sangue nel lavandino molto
simpatico che sono contento che facciate
dei livelli allegri l'importante è
rimanere allegri ragazzi e pieri sul
gioco per divertirsi che mi sono molto
contenti visto spirito rimanga porco
demonio c'è un ragno gigante corri sono
vivo ho sfondato un muro ma fa niente
c'è un ragno che è sceso dal soffitto
speriamo che non arrivi fin qua non
credo
grazie io che per la mano che mi hai
dato
bravo grazie zio veramente non so come
ci si assicura che difficile qui si
lamenta che lo lanciano al sellino
ragazzo di la grancia
non ci servono tanto mia non ci serve
neanche cosa per proseguire mi porta a
lui mi porta al mio amico giochiamo come
lo chiamò fernando no tutti fernando
litigiose la melma di cognome fa la
melma tutto staccato credo che la melma
sia un cognome vero che hanno rifiutato
nessun signor la melma che sta volando
questo video mi dispiace mi spieghi
questa parte iniziale che senso ha e la
cosa piu critiche abbia mai visto e
tratto mi lega pure il gioco c'è una
roba orribile da vedere dopo sto video
non dovremo più senza un motivo
allora brutto schifo non esco via a
beccare luke distranza cosa come faccio
a scendere vi si spaccherà le gambe
vai vai senza senza gambe senza denti
senza la dignità forse se non mi mette
questa scena non si può mettere su
youtube poteva non si può mettere noi
non posso non far rivedere questa
giampiero orcadi quella vecchia crolli
c'è uno che uno vuole mettere ca pranzi
ok ho trovato un ascensore molto carino
perché sono tutti a 90 in questo video
con il problema spiegatemi spiegatemi
che il problema di questo dislivello
c'è un input quale preferisco quello a
quello che è successo prima
comunque va bene andiamo mai perfetto
meno male che non è ciò che ha fatto da
esca era uno scarafaggio importante che
non ci siano ragni poi va tutto bene
brehme ami da trasportare possono fare
qua non ho capito ma ho fatto qualcosa
non ho capito cosa è stato fatto
c'è un topo con corno che mi ha ucciso
cosa fare qua basi stupido ma avrai
proseguire ma dai basta a metà non è
tutti che i parenti a jean perde basta
al suo livello mi sono rotto le
pacchetto dark penso che sia mi chiama
sento la musica aspetta è questa qua
allora questi che si pigliano a cartoni
faccia cosa devo fare nel ghetto salve
devo fare islanda è uno sport pericoloso
io ho sempre starebbe ragazzi sempre
indossare casco anche mentre giocato a
basket
io soprattutto nel ghetto perché io sono
saltato in aria per non aver fatto
assolutamente niente poi ho mai grande
girls cose sui cerchi e devo esplodere
stesso motivo devo entrare nel canestro
bisogna fare o quasi due anni di milan
channel uk lui la madonna nera hayward
non ho capito cosa è successo non fate
domande per cortesia andiamo avanti
ragazzi cosa devo fare press spacebar ok
mise scassato tutto va bene fa niente
prepara fuori in fact che bisogna
preparare o cosa devo prepararmi ma lui
e faccia mica sono io il personaggio che
ne so c'è un tasto per prepararmi
all'impatto cieco ma cosa vuol dire non
lo so come devo preparano c'è un tasto
di preparazione all'impatto
ma cosa devo fare non lo so ehi perfetto
tutto a posto
se vorrei vi stanno prendendo per il
culo però non ne sono sicurissimo
rifacciamo sono vietate una valanga o
mio dio
cosa ha fatto e non ho capito niente e
quindi sa dove entra la che è veloce
però bravissimo maestria e mi sto misti
tenendo conto che sto strisciando non so
dove
ecco l'ho preso preso meno male no marco
demonio è il 9 giugno aerea
devi entrare ne coprono di stare fermo
quando entri che sono un problema
ok non so quale parte del corpo
esattamente st penzolando in questo
dietro però penzola quinto proprio sex
shop free wifi land grab del rock
va bene ci provo oggi super mario 64 e
solo fatto sicuro sicuro con lotito mi
sono fatto sicuro sicuro ha sì l'avevo
fatto ma tipo quando avevo 0 anni quindi
non mi ricordo è ancora ero vergine
allora gli amanti ragazzi cos'è porca
vacca l'hanno fatto anche difficile
aspetta a livelli più difficili e
pinguini sono fatti tutti oggi che
cacchio allora fa mica perché poi
comunque in soffermare società 4 entravi
nei quadri io voglio la le masse di
questo gioco scusatemi ragazzi
l'interramento di dire una roba del
genere ma la voglia di intendo
collaboriamo spesso ascoltatevi perché
ci ho ragione io ho fatto una remata
strade di grazie ragazzi semmai uscirà
un aree vaste aree di super mario 64
ricordate di chi l'ha detto a nintendo
l'ho detto c'è la prova il video vediamo
se no sono arrivo a devo prenderne 8 di
stelle farka vacca dai ragazzi per
cristina d'avena forza bravo vedi che la
forme di che pensare a cristina d'avena
in qualche modo ti dà la potenza aem
king bob omb ai giornalai questo mi sa
che lo diceva anche nel gioco non mi
ricordo va giù testa di culo perfetto
aiuto sono tornato 130 aspettare attivo
che non so dove devo andare a sei assi e
sono più livelli addirittura mi blocca
anche la porta con la in alto alla fine
prima di semplicissimo questo poi devo
fare tutto senza morire mai
chi è veramente un casino aiuto stai
calmo era solo una punturina bravo bravo
lo zio bravo occhio che vai di
sospettati perfetto
siamo a metà stelle ragazzi metà stelle
non è male non è male occhio occhio
occhio aspetto aspetto aperta chi va
piano va sano e va a metano occhio qua
perché perfetto perfetto perfetto che
giocatore è ragazzi oggi fare un di me
in terza persona su una problematica
oggi sono patrizia allora perfetto o
madonna come ho rischiato quarda la mia
vita neanche alla maturità rischiato
rosita non ci passo forse devo fare il
contrario aiuto grazie a posta possa
portare tutto risolto non un risotto un
caffè che già due divennero abbiamo
finiti porco il demonio porco non posso
continuare a non finire livelli almeno
questo voglio finire che cacchio taglio
fino a che non ci riesco cioè fino a due
ore di tagli wells hack'n'slash dio mio
ragazzi due ore per i turn acqua quindi
non mi morire per cortesia t'ammazzo non
prendo neanche le stelle me ne sbatto
vedi che alla fine il karma mi colpisce
il re del pop michael jackson diventa
michael jackson michael jackson eccolo
mi ha lanciato un sasso
mi ha sparato michael jackson mentre
smooth criminal c'è il software di
smooth criminal hanno fatto con è
permesso io la musica ha raggiunto
livelli 2020 signori 2020 oggi stiamo
arrivando this is it
ok c'era il bis di michael bay dai
ragazzi di cosa parliamo
questo è un livello ancora le prime e
seleziona le difficoltà a let's go
quindi
cosa devo fare
sono morto sono vivo scherzavo perché le
vittime sono morto vediamo cosa ci
propone in easy madonna così salvato
bellissimo non ho niente sotto il pube
ma fa niente
non capisco cosa devo fare ok ok non
vedo oh mio dio
oh mio dio me in tutte ste cose devo
fare in hard ma sei falso ma come potrei
mai farlo in hardware ma do sono vivo
non è che cosa per pedalare pro pedalò
com'è possibile tutto questo
sono vivo non ho le gambe ma pedalò
perché la fisica in questo gioco non è
mai esistita sarebbe da braida un buon
pit bull tourbus time della verde figura
basta non ci ho più voglia dei ragazzi
spero che il video vi sia piaciuto
questo era a 190 ma su un bacino
grazie per aver visto il video e chiede
al canale spiace dalla campanellina e
come sempre noi ci vediamo alle
pressioni della ragazza
[Musica]